今日はこちらしていくは分です
ban
んんん
ben ん
1分
今日はまた言葉の勉強について話ししたいと思うんですよ
それでテーマはね今日はその辺か我々
その知らないうちに変化が起こっています
有名な芸者の轍哲学者が減ら来てスアの良いたようにですね
同じ川にその足をにどう
分入れることはできません
だから感じてないにしてもいつも
変わっています我々も市も進歩しています
まそういうテーマなんですよ
このは私のビデオに興味ありましたら是非登録してください
金のところに
そのクリックすればいい
知らせ
お届けします
そしてぜひ陰気にさんを打ってください
僕と一緒に曲言葉を勉強しましょう
性ですね今日はバンクーバーでね天気が良い良くなくて
雨が多くてそれじゃあ護符できませんということで
あのそれじゃあまあアラビア語勉強しようとそして集中的に3時間
その愛パールで私のそれらのレッスンはですね
主にまあの
ポンティカスアンジェラの podcast かあの敵とに行ったりスクラブして読ん
でますけれどもそれで今日は僕のその static て統計はですねええ確かに良い
さの新しい
そのしてる単語の数が169増えました
結果的にそして新しいその言葉を保存したっていうか整備しましたリンクをつくりまし
たのが風が200
a それで
マーゴ1800以上の単語もに読みました
そういう統計がリンクて出るわけですよそれだけ僕は今日
活躍しました
しかししかしながら
その4割ない座りながらですね勉強しながら動き感じたことはですね
その端も安島た時と3時間後の私が
全然進歩してないっていう感じがあるわけですよアラビア語の数字は一生だと
その
新しい言葉をその勉強したっていうか思えましたというか
感じてないわけですよ基本的には僕はレベル同じだという僕の習慣的な
まあ感じなんですけれども実際にはそうじゃないんです
実際にはこの統計が知らせているように
新しい単語勉強できたとたくさんの
その単語も読みましたとだから no 金変わりました
少しでも変化がありました
だから芸者の哲学者が言いましたようにもそれもに千何百年前ですけれどもやはり
二度と同じ川にその足が踏み入れない入れることができませんという意味でいつも変化
変換変換変化があるんで
9アラビア語に対してもですね今日の3時間でじゃあ
非常にも進歩しましたという感じはないんですけれども
始まった陶器に比べてものアレアラビア語がもうどうだけでアラビアの文字は読めなく
て
少しスクール少しずつ少しずつ進歩したわけですよ
結果的に今のあの
ポンディクラスですね angelo の podcast 聞けば
かなりの部分わかるわけですよ知らない単語がそんなに多くはないんです
だから実際には進歩があった日は事故の死亡は感じない
えっ
前にも言いましたその
俺今一つの道5人でね園生の
そういう専門家ですけれども脳がねあの
勉強することに
その出来てる機械なんですよやるしかいないんなんでしょ勉強します
脳が必ず勉強しますしかしゆっくりゆっくりだから我々は知らないうちに
ノーマいろんなその新しい経験新しい繁
いい子その中からある程度整理して
へ猛猛勉強というか覚えてるわけでしょ
必ず必ずだからあの変化というのは必ずある
だから勉強しているときにいやーもう
どうしようもないんだと全然進歩してないんだという風に考えないでください
続ければ続ければ必ず進歩する
それからもう一つは今日僕のように3時間も集中的にその勉強するのがいいと思うん
ですよ
ちょいのはアルティある時はね
そのもう3時間30分だけやったらねぇいいやつ
[音楽]
あれでしょつまらないとか難しいとか
しかし3時間やりながらさらにその良い奥が出てくる
そこまでも入り込んでね勉強するとなおさら
まあ効果的だと思うんですよしかし基本的には続ければ勉強できる
続ければ変化が起こるだから同じ革では内地というわけなんですよ
それじゃあ今日はどうもそこまでさようなら
ん
dan
うんん
5分
うん